[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey there film fanatics i'm lord garrett
and welcome to another episode of rt
essentials this week is dedicated to
those who like some screams with their
holiday cheer those who want some black
and orange with their red and green and
aren't quite ready to trade out the
spooky cobwebs for the sparkly garlands
maybe there's just something about the
incessantly joyous music that makes you
want to hide out in a snow-covered cabin
they start playing in september i swear
whatever it may be this list of
christmas horror movies is for you
black
[Music]
on the christmas walk to the front door
and leave the house
what's wrong
please miss bradford please just do as i
tell you
okay
i'll get it
no no don't do that jess
yes
the caller is in the house the calls are
coming from the house
yes
yes get
sledding in first we have the canadian
slasher black christmas directed by bob
clark who later went on to direct a
christmas story which didn't exactly
have the same
edge black christmas stars olivia hussey
kia delia margot kidder and john saxon
and was inspired by the 1960s urban
legend the babysitter and the man
upstairs now if you're not familiar with
this tale it's not sized in the title
there's a babysitter the phone rings a
creepy man tells her to check on the
children she freaks out and calls the
police they show up and inform her that
the call came from upstairs and the
children are dead in black christmas a
group of sorority sisters start
receiving anonymous lewd phone calls
during the holiday season the calls
escalate to threats and then one of the
sisters goes missing there's also news
that a local adolescent girl has been
murdered and a serial killer is on the
it's loose right
pretty agnes
[Music]
don't you tell what we did
[Music]
turns out the mysterious killer is much
closer than the girls may have thought
and well you do the maths the film
received mixed reviews upon its release
but in time earned retroactive praise
gaining a cult following and ranking on
many notable lists of best horror movies
of all time black christmas is also
cited as a pioneer in the slasher
subgenre and the influence on iconic
films like john carpenter's halloween is
undeniable in fact before halloween was
released clark and carpenter worked on a
project together and carpenter expressed
his own interest in seeing a sequel for
black christmas clarke had no intention
of making another horror but did present
his hypothetical plot idea to carpenter
the killer from black christmas is
caught he escapes from a mental
institution and then returns to the same
house for more knifing delight clark
even entitled the working idea halloween
black christmas was novelized by author
lee hayes in 1976 and has been remade
twice once in 2006 and again in 2019 it
is essential twisted holiday
entertainment that is of course if
you're dreaming of a black christmas
krampus
merry christmas
[Music]
[Music]
we've all experienced some family
dysfunction brought on by the holidays
in krampus a young boy named max is so
disillusioned by his own family's
bickering that he completely turns his
back on christmas hey lisa didn't make
max sleep in an attic and then screw off
to paris without him hashtag you filthy
animals max's loss of the festive spirit
unleashes krampus a horned demonic beast
that seeks to punish non-believers as
krampus lays siege to the entire
neighborhood max and his family must
learn to cooperate or else meet their
frightful demise would you rather face
krampus or pesci food for thought yeah
dorothy
finish it
with pleasure
trick-or-treat director michael doherty
conceptualized krampus in 2011 and after
several iterations of the script began
principal photography in 2015. the film
received mixed to positive reviews many
noting colette and scott's performances
and applauding doherty's ability to
blend holiday humor with horror on a
budget of 15 million dollars krampus
earned 61.5 million at the box office
making it a success which some
attributed to the unique christmas
themed horror genre there's a thematic
lesson here in loving your family no
matter what but it kind of gets lost in
the whole horned demon from hell
terrorizing children during christmas
thing
gremlins
[Music]
this next film needs a little
introduction chances are you've heard of
a gremlin maybe even dressed up as one
at halloween at the very least you know
gizmo who looks a lot like baby yoda who
forgot to shave goonies and harry potter
legend chris columbus crafted the script
for gremlins after hearing what sounded
like a platoon of mice skittering around
in the darkness of his loft the story
was written as a speck but caught the
attention of spielberg who became the
executive producer and exclaimed it's
one of the most original things i've
come across in many years which is why i
bought it that is quite the stamp of
approval for a budding writer one two
three four five noon
now can i have one
oh i don't know hey look at that one's
got a cute little stripe on its head
gremlins follows a gadget salesman who
seeks out a special gift for his son he
comes across an adorable creature called
a mogwai at a shop in chinatown but the
owner is reluctant to sell after some
debate the owner agrees to part with the
murguai but offers a fateful warning it
must never be exposed to bright light
water or fed after midnight of course
all of these things do happen and as a
result a gang of gremlins ransacked the
picturesque town on christmas eve and
this is why you don't frivolously buy
mogwais as christmas presents people
[Applause]
[Music]
it's hard to measure the true impact of
gremlins seeing as it transcends cult
status and fires on all cylinders of the
industry critics lauded director joe
dante's mingling of comedy and horror
which contrasted against the idealistic
christmas setting the film was also a
box office smash earning
212.9 million dollars against a budget
of 11 million dollars additionally it
spawned a sequel and a third film which
is currently in active development not
to mention the large-scale merchandising
campaign that mass-produced gremlin
action figures and dolls as well as top
sprinted trading cards and a video game
with a certified fresh score of 85 on
the tomato meter make gremlins the final
of your christmas horror movie tree
rare exports a christmas tale
put down your weapons
and smile
as nice
as you can
move slowly
and do exactly
as i say
this is not sand what
it's one of santa's little helpers
ever wondered what would happen if you
traveled far north into finland and
uncovered the tomb of santa claus
neither well either way rare exports is
the story of a young boy named pitari
and his friend jusso who do in fact dig
up santa's burial except this is no
holly jolly santa this is an evil and
monstrous santa that has been
slaughtering reindeer and kidnapping
children finnish director jalmari
hollander based the script on his 2003
short film rare exports inc and its
sequel about a band of hunters who trap
wild santa clauses the short films
gained a cold following on the internet
and hollander was able to team up with
producers and finance the feature-length
version
[Music]
the film was critically hailed with
roger ebert exclaiming that it's a
rather brilliant lump of coal for your
stocking and calling it an r rated santa
claus origin story crossed with the
thing the hollywood reporter described
the movie as a fiendishly entertaining
christmas yarn rooted in northern
european legend and lore and the new
york times called the movie a thing of
frigid beauty and twisted playfulness
rare exports is also certified fresh
with a tomato meter score of 90 and an
audience score of 70
clearly we have finland to thank for
this rare export and much welcomed
addition to the christmas horror genre
santa's
sleight santa
yes virginia there is a santa claus
professional wrestler bill goldberg
stars in santa's sleigh a christmas
slash a comedy written and directed by
david steinman kudos on the word play
she loves a palm crusading across the
globe on a sleigh driven by hell dear
santa played by goldberg tortures
terrorizes and slaughters everyone in
his path often incorporating holiday
themes into his acts of violence such as
using the star atop a christmas tree as
a ninja star and even going as far as
murdering someone with their own menorah
which i think has to just be offensive
right
you pick the wrong delhi fatso
here's the stockings
the film has been described as brainless
cheesy stupid and satirical but that it
had plenty of laughs so that's something
unless it's those ironic laughs you know
in the room kind of way with an audience
score of 43 this one doesn't quite top
the list but hey if nothing else watch
it to see goldberg acting as a deranged
santa
better watch out
[Music]
so this is christmas and once again
parents are taking off and leaving their
kid behind have we learned nothing folks
at least in better watch out these
parents hire a babysitter named ashley
to look after their son luke while
they're gone as always things go
sideways pretty quickly twelve-year-old
luke develops romantic feelings for
ashley and starts acting all sorts of
crazy but that's nothing compared to the
life-threatening home intruders that the
two will have to fend off if they hope
to make it through the holidays
[Music]
better watch out is a mostly australian
production shot in sydney and starring
natives olivia dejong levi miller and ed
oxenbold however director and co-writer
chris peckover is american and
originally planned to shoot in south
carolina on a budget of 500 000
plans shifted when producer brett thorne
quest offered 3 million to peck over to
shoot it in australia and use local
talent good on you mate the film
received generally positive feedback
with the guardian giving it 4 out of 5
stars and entitling their review
deranged mind game and faultless
performances in christmas horror better
watch out is also certified fresh with a
tomato meet a score of 89 oh there's
also a home alone inspired murder in
this film so you better watch out for
that
jack frost
killer snowman is it yours yes
no
oh yes
i think the black ice slider is
officially open
[Music]
and all different horses and all the
king's men couldn't give a rat's ass
about tyler's little snowman huh
not to be confused with that abominable
michael keaton flick jack frost is a
direct-to-video comedy slasher set in
the fictional town of snow mountain
notorious serial killer jack frost is on
route to his execution when he gets into
a bizarre accident and consequently
transforms into a murderous mutant
snowman seems a little fortuitous that
his birth name is jack frost and this
would be his fate but it is a serial
killing snowman so some suspension of
disbelief is in order wait please
we know it's you jack
all right wait
i can help
maybe turn you back
but i'm having so much fun just the way
i am jack frost was released on vhs by
apex entertainment and dvd by scimitar
entertainment in 1997. for our younger
viewers a vhs was this boxy tape
cassette that blockbuster would penalize
you for not rewinding please don't ask
what a blockbuster is the film was
produced on a shoestring budget with
director michael cooney claiming that
his movie identity had a catering budget
that exceeded the entire cost of jack
frost with such modest finances it's no
surprise the special effects completely
suffered but that's a part of the charm
and a major reason the film developed a
cult following jack frost was critically
detested earning a seven percent score
on the tomato meter and an audience
score of 30 percent but that didn't stop
cooney from making a sequel jack frost 2
revenge of the mutant killer snowman
the children
up next is the british horror thriller
the children directed by tom shankland
and starring ava berthissel and hannah
toynton the plot is based on a story by
paul andrew williams and takes place at
an upscale english estate in late
december where two families gather for a
weekend of winter fun and bonding all of
this goes south when the children
contract a strange disease that turns
them into savage psychotic killers not
exactly what they had in mind for a
relaxing christmas vacation
[Music]
[Music]
the film boasts impressive
cinematography and the snowy wooded
surroundings make for a shining esque
serenity that is perfectly juxtaposed
with the vicious creepiness of the young
killers the children received generally
positive reviews with time out
eloquently stating this taboo shattering
movie taps into primal fears about the
unknowability of children its
bloodstained virgin snow and insidious
terror recalling cruel fairy tales and
demon child movies such as the omen this
film also has one of the best taglines
in any movie ever you brought them into
the world now they will take you out
maybe this is what happens when your
kids aren't happy with their presence
silent night deadly night
[Music]
[Music]
this next slasher tells the story of a
young boy named billy who is raised in
an abusive catholic orphanage after
witnessing the murder of his parents on
christmas eve billy grows into a
tormented adult who has a psychological
breakdown during the holiday season
which sends him on a killing spree
dressed as santa silent night deadly
night was directed by charles celia jr
and stars robert brian wilson lillian
schauban gilmar mccormick and b-movie
regular linnea quigley who earned the
nickname scream queen due to her
frequent appearances in low budget
horror films
you've been good all year
you
see santa claus tonight you better run
boy
you better run for your life
because of the overt use of a violent
killer dressed as santa claus this
became one of the most controversial
releases of the 1980s the pta fought for
the film to be removed from theaters and
the advertisements that aired between
family-friendly series led to parents
complaining that their children were now
terrified of santa tri-star pictures who
originally distributed the film
responded by pulling all ads and
withdrawing the picture furthermore the
film was condemned by siskel and ebert
with siskel going as far as personally
calling out the production crew on air
saying shame on you and stating that the
money made from this film was in fact
blood money so i'm guessing no two
thumbs up for that one hey cisco
though silent night deadly night was
never officially re-released in theaters
it was distributed on vhs in 1986.
despite all the drama the film developed
a cult following and spawned an
impressive four sequels and a loose
remake in 2012. can't imagine how the
pta feels about that one
the lodge
i need my pills and we're just gonna
walk to the
nearest town and
call your dad and then he's gonna come
pick us up
so we have to pack your things
what are you talking about we can't
leave
it's not up for discussion hey
look outside grace that's crazy
we don't even have our jackets
we're not going
we'll go alone
you won't make it
last and certainly not least we have the
lodge directed and written by filmmaking
duo veronica franz and severan fayala
this horror thriller stars riley keogh
jaden martell leah mchugh alicia
silverstone and richard armitage we
follow a young family to a secluded and
i mean secluded winter cabin for a
little holiday retreat the father is
forced to abruptly depart for a work
emergency and leaves the two children in
the care of his new girlfriend grace who
the kids haven't fully warmed up to yet
when a heavy blizzard strikes the three
find themselves trapped inside the lodge
and grace's dark past creeps up to haunt
her
what i was right greece is from his book
on cults
oh my god
radical christian sect
everyone committed suicide except for
her
she's supposed to bring the teachings of
the sect to the public
and you will find salvation
repent if you're into cults which
judging by the popularity of
documentaries like wild wild country
many people are this is the film for you
in classic jonestown fashion grace was
the only survivor in a mass suicide led
by her father aaron marshall the film is
filmed with religious symbolism and
psychological terror also these kids are
pretty nasty like not in a murderous
children kind of way but more of a
parent trap hey is the new girl kind of
way keo delivers an exemplary
performance as grace and critics did not
fail to notice consequence of sound
called this a career best for the
actress and the los angeles times
praised kyo as the movie's strongest
asset and furthermore stated that she
can seize and hold the screen with
electrifying force the lodge premiered
at sundance in january of 2019 and had
its official big screen run in february
of 2020 reaching 322 theatres in the us
with a certified fresh score of 74 on
the tomato meter be sure to add this one
to your holiday horror rotation while
you're at it invite those cult-loving
friends build a gingerbread lodge and
make cereal killing snowmen just don't
drink the eggnog yeah and there you have
it our top picks for christmas horror
movies as always we can't go over every
film that fits the bill so please don't
stick your hell dear on us if we happen
to leave one out i'm mod garrett and
thank you for watching today's rt
essentials stick around because we've
got some magical movie-based media
coming your way and please always
remember the most important rule the
rule that you can't forget no matter how
much he begs never feed your mogwai
after midnight
trust me
[Music]
you